Yeah,
10 years,
10 years.
He's a long time,
a decade.
And in many ways it seems so far in the past
in some ways.
Yeah.
It doesn't seems so far away at all.
It isn't hard to remember being deployed in Ramadi,
Iraq in the summer of 2006
okay.
And yes,
sometimes that seems like a distant place,
a long time ago,
Britain,
yet.
Yeah.
Sometimes it feels like we were just there yesterday.
The sweltering heat,
the dust,
the danger,
the crystal clear focus on our mission when we had,
but one purpose in our lives to close with and destroy an evil enemy bent on
destroying us and our way of life.
And it doesn't take much
for the mind to return there,
to regain that mindset,
to get into the combat mode.
And remember,
remember the operations out in the city,
remember the tracer rounds in the night sky explosions,
shaking the earth,
the weight of body armor and weapons and gear on our shoulders.
Remember the stress and the violence and the sweat and the blood.
And remember the eval,
the pure evil that infected the city and committed savage,
vile.
And disgusting acts of mortal sin.
Yeah.
Murder,
rape,
okay.
And torture
and inside that dark world.
Yeah.
Homeworld world ripped apart by war or world war.
Sometimes humanity seemed all but lost.
Yeah.
That is where we got to see and experience the polar opposite,
the counter to all that darkness.
Against that backdrop of evil.
We young men.
Yeah,
we band of brothers.
We got to witness light and life and love so strong that it makes the darkness
feed and makes the evil cower and hide it's wretched face.
Evil bows down when it sees the bond we developed with the soldiers and marines,
we fought alongside
evil cannot contest the bond
we formed with our brothers seals
with whom we become so close that there is no stronger force in the world.
Nothing more powerful,
nothing more meaningful than knowing that these men,
these frog men,
that we would do anything for each other.
We saw powerful acts of heroism and courage on an almost daily basis,
which reassured us solemnly that good would triumph over evil.
And amongst all that glory,
there were a few men,
the true heroes,
the ones that rose above the rest of us to symbolize and personify courage and
faith at selflessness and love.
Mark Allen Lee was one of those rare men,
one of those heroes,
one of the few men in my life that I literally described as a sinked.
That is who mark was a mighty warrior who's ferocity and combat was perfectly
balanced by faith and humor and compassion.
The man that left his mark on everyone that he met,
a mark of happiness and positivity and of humility and of joy.
A man whose love for his family and friends were so unbounded.
It's so limitless
that you could actually feel it emanating from his heart.
Okay.
And now
he has left his mark on the world.
Mark Lee.
Okay.
Mark Allen Lee,
when faced with fear,
who else could bring a smile
when faced with sadness?
Okay,
who else could bring laughter
when faced with heat?
Who else could bring love
and when faced with death,
who else could stand and say,
take me Lord,
not my brothers.
I will be their shield now from def.
Take me.
Hey,
let them live on.
And that is what mark did
full of youth and energy and courage and humor
and full of love.
He stood,
he stood against evil and he stood against death and he gave his life
for his brothers.
Yeah.
And for our freedom
on August 2nd
yeah.
in all Ramadi,
Iraq,
10 years ago.
Yeah.
And in those 10 years,
okay.
Think of all that has happened in our lives.
Big events like marriages,
children born birthdays,
new houses,
new jobs,
new careers
in small events.
Uh,
morning,
surf session
launch with your buddies at weekend in the mountains.
Yeah.
A cold ice tea on a hot summer's Day.
Smile
or laugh,
life,
joy,
happiness.
And every moment of that happiness is a gift.
A gift,
a gift given to us by mark who sacrificed everything for us.
Yeah.
Who gave up his own precious smile.
So we could all have ours.
Now.
I can tell you without a shred of doubt that on this day today,
mark would not want tears.
He would not want sadness,
he would not want sorrow.
He would want smiles and laughter and joy because that was his gift to us.
Every smile,
every laugh,
every ounce of life and love is all a gift
from a warrior,
a friend,
a comedian,
a son,
a brother
I hero,
saint.
And what do we owe mark
for mark?
Yeah.
Each and every one of us must relish the gift that he gave to us and cherish
each and every day.
Yeah.
While remembering the incredible man that gave us this gift
of life
and too,
okay,
the seals
that are listening,
the frog,
man,
you owe mark what we owe all of our fallen brothers the grave commitment to
carry the fire.
Yeah.
To hold the torch and hold it high,
to take the fight to the enemy.
Every chance you get without mercy and without remorse
until they are vanquished
and there is peace.
Thank you mark.
We will never forget you.
God bless Mark's family.
God bless the teams.
God bless America,
and God bless Mark Allen Lee.